hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the more problematic human
emotions drives Dynamics is that of envy
and Seneca is going to discuss this in
relation to anger and the workings of
Envy in book three of his on anger in
two chapters in particular chapters 30
and 31 and he begins this discussion in
sort of an offhanded way to show an
example and then he goes on to explain
how it is that Envy works and so he says
suppose another's been treated more
generously okay so this is a typical
occasion of Envy what should we do we
should take pleasure in what it is that
we have in ours quite literally NOS
without engaging it or making
comparisons
so what is a comparison well we look at
what we've got and we look at what the
other person has and here's where Envy
tends to arise we don't just make a
comparison in the sense of judging oh
that's bigger this is smaller
we start to mix in values the value of
this is less in comparison to that
greater thing over there and we also
start to make connections right that
person gave this other person over there
more than they gave me they must value
that other person more than they value
me now I start to get angry right
because I'm making these comparisons and
Seneca points out a general idea that I
think is quite true
he talks about people being tormented or
like literally like turned up you know
turned around
by others greater happiness follicular
the the fact that other people are
enjoying more or seem to be enjoying
more and that this interferes with
another that very person being happy
themselves so so long as I make my
happiness depend not just on having
enough having what is good enough for me
but on its connection and comparison to
what other people have I am actually
interfering with my own happiness and he
goes on and says suppose I have less
than I hoped well perhaps I hoped for
more than I should have and then he
points out we should fear most and he
uses that word uh fear anger that arises
from this quarter why well it's the most
destructive and there's also another
feature to it it's not just the most
destructive most inclined to attack the
things we hold sacred it's it's most
inclined to transgress to cross
boundaries that shouldn't be to go too
far we could say and he provides us with
some examples of this he says more
friends than enemies finished off the
deified Julius that's Julius Caesar he
hadn't satisfied their insatiable hopes
he'd wanted to no one made more generous
use of Victory but how could he satisfy
such Relentless desires when each one of
them lusted after all that a single man
had in his power right so you know this
is a great example you could never
really satisfy everybody people are
going to be envious you should be on the
guard against the anger that arise rises
from this Spirit of comparison and
saying it's not enough for me and you
have done me wrong by not giving me what
I want
he goes on and he says and this is at
the beginning of chapter 31 nobody who
is looking at another possessions is
pleased with their own so another's
possessions are Eliana
respiciente looking at examining what it
is that another person has this again
prevents us from being happy and how
does anger rather than just mere
distress or grief come from this he says
we grow angry even with the goods we
have
because another's ahead of us
and literally precedes us uh you know
onto Cadence right so we get angry not
just with people but even with the the
wealth the good things that it is that
we do possess for not being enough
because other people got there first and
this could be wealth this could be
social status this could even be things
like being the first person to make a
comment on a video you know people
sometimes uh will say first right as if
that's somehow important and then
somebody else could get mad and be like
oh I watch this all the way through I
didn't just put a comment there you know
I deserve to be first well yeah sure you
know people can get upset over anything
and he goes out and he says um what
monstrous Envy stalks the man who envies
only a few right and so even if we have
any Envy we're really getting ourselves
in trouble and then he talks about
unreasonable people who receive
something and it might be quite nice but
they count it as an insult in Nuria that
they didn't get more from the person so
yeah we again we could think about this
with countless examples somebody uh goes
on a date with somebody and the date
goes quite well and they get a good
night kiss and they're like you're not
going to invite me inside for a night
cap and then they're like no first date
you know maybe next time maybe the time
after that and now they're mad because
they didn't get more right or you give
somebody a book and they're like why
didn't you buy me the whole collection
this book is a used copy why didn't you
buy me a new coffee we could go on and
on and on right people at dinner looking
at the the other table and being like oh
why did I order this that looks so much
better can't I have both you know the
waiter says sure if you want to order it
and pay for it but uh you've already
ordered something right so
unreasonable people get angry quite
easily he gives some examples from Roman
life he gave me a pratership but I had
hoped for a consulship uh so you know
these are both like high offices being
prey tour console uh sort of like you
know being made vice president but they
didn't make you president are you still
vice president right that's still
something pretty good oh they appointed
you to associate professor but you're
not full Professor yet you're still
associate professor in a Time by the way
when you know much of the professor it
is actually being taught by adjuncts and
working in precarious conditions if you
actually have a full-time secure job you
ought to be happy about that a little
bit of a side note there he goes on as
well and he says he gave me 12 fast days
but didn't make me an ordinary Council
he wished the year be reckoned by my
name but I still don't have a priesthood
I've been chosen to be a member of
Priestly college but why only one right
so these are all like offices and Seneca
is going higher and higher and higher
with it and saying these people are
never satisfied they're never happy
because they're always looking at what
they don't have finally the other
example he's crowned my social standing
but he's contributed nothing to my
estate he's given me what he was obliged
to give but he extended nothing of his
own so I mean people are doing great
favors for you and you're like but they
didn't do this other thing well that's
you know constantly demanding more and
at this point we could actually say
maybe it's not just Envy maybe it's also
avarice or greed not just in terms of
money but in terms of status as well but
all of these are causes for other people
getting angry so we've got to watch them
if we realize they're like that but it's
also for ourselves we can quite easily
get upset with life other people what we
have what we don't have
so what's the remedy how should we uh
deal with this he says gratitude
it rather say thanks AGA gratias gracias
is thanks to the other person AGA means
to bestow it on them say thanks for what
it is that you're actually getting
because it is something good right
and then he says wait for the rest
and be glad you don't yet have all you
can and here Sonica says something
really quite interesting usually the
stoics including Seneca are kind of down
on Hope space uh in in Latin here he's
actually saying that hopes
are among the pleasures of life vote
right so he he tells us that it's one of
life's Pleasures to have something left
to hope for so you know if you didn't
get everything but you have some
prospects of getting something decent
enjoy those prospects
Delight in them for a bit so here Seneca
is actually endorsing a reasonable kind
of hope and then he talks about
surpassing others right he says suppose
you've surpassed all others be glad
you're first in the heart of your friend
so that's one possibility if you
actually have a lot of stuff wonderful
right if your best friend is best
friends with you cool but what if others
have passed you up in terms of
friendship or in terms of wealth or in
terms of position or in terms of beauty
or we can go on and on and on because
anything that we can compare we can find
ourselves to be lesser and here he says
something else that's kind of
interesting if you are yourself
surpassed
consider the fact that you aren't at the
very bottom just by not being at the top
right he he says that
um
consider how many more are behind you
than ahead of you you know so here's
here's a good example so you know you've
got money in the bank but it's not a ton
of money
um you know there's always going to be
people who have more money banking in
that same bank than you do
yeah but you're not broke right you're
not destitute you're not living on the
street you actually have what we call an
emergency fund that's good you know so
this leads to a important complaint
which we can turn into a principle we
want to keep truer accounts we want to
keep a sense of perspective or
proportion about what it is that we have
and Seneca is going to note something
here which by the way he talks about at
much greater length in his longer work
on benefits he says you want to know
your biggest fault you don't keep true
accounts you put a high value on what
you've given a low value on what you've
received what you really want to do is
have true accurate values on both what
you're giving and what you're receiving
from other people so that you can keep
these things in proper perspective
realize the goods that you have are
Goods be thankful for the things that
you do have and avoid falling into the
kind of envy that will transform itself
fairly quickly into being offended and
getting angry and then losing control
and probably damaging your relationships
and certainly depriving yourself
of the happiness that otherwise you
could in fact enjoy